I'm co-directing various love Lotus Korea with everyone. Thank you for your cooperation. Yes, I'm going to
direct Magic Cross already
. I'm Genji.
I told you today that you shouldn't
have a famous place, but
if you always use it for gi nations, you'll always have yourself. I
thought how to make this series for the examinees
from the world in the blender.
I think it's the continuity of the world view and mail it to me.
That's because, like Mr. Flavor King, the expression of the next town
is the same, and I hope that there are countless characters in Mr. Perry's cooking.
I was hiding this without asking in politics because it was interesting
.
Wow, ah,
ah, it's about August. About 40 pairs of physical quantity
sing the power of the image of the loop from the sky.
I don't know if there's a past
I've doubted my identity w do you do